[Music]
i think i want to get one of each
we can do that lara jean and peter
kavinsky's romance
is epic but so are ross butler's
impromptu dance moves
did you know that lana and noah adlib
some of the final film's most vulnerable
lines and most of trevor and chris's
flirting was
unscripted here are all the improvised
moments from netflix's most romantic
trilogy
okay one two three
when the characters were having a blast
at the prom the cast
was having a pretty good time too so
good in fact that most of their dance
moves were completely unscripted
madeleine arthur revealed that chris and
travis tango was choreographed by jordan
fisher who was on set the day of filming
but her and ross butler decided to make
the routine
even more elaborate as for trevor's
break dancing
that was all ross big painting in a big
museum like a buddha chelly trevor and
chris's witty banter throughout the
series is also a product of madeleine
and ross's talent for improv
and their incredible chemistry when
trevor picks up chris for the prom
the playful flirtation between the two
lovebirds was entirely made up on the
spot
your mission should you choose to accept
it is to meet me back here in the lobby
at 2100 hours
the best moments for the cast are when
they get to have fun all together
so filming the montage for the new york
city trip was one of the most freeing
and exciting things they got to do
and it was the perfect opportunity to
say goodbye to the series in their own
way
the cast got to run around the city
eating ice cream taking selfies and
basically just
being kids while the cameras followed
them around and caught all their
funniest antics
they had free reign to go off script and
just act like teenagers
you're welcome oh you speak english the
scenes of the covey sisters in south
korea
also had their fair share of unscripted
moments where the cast got to do some
sisterly bonding
those karaoke dance moves were the
creation of the actresses
they got to hang their very own lock
near their characters and
that unique cafe they shot at was a
last-minute scout decision by the book's
author jenny han
it's called greem cafe and it really is
in seoul
you strip it out while you try
while visiting little cupcake bake shop
during their trip to new york city
lara jean finally tells peter that she
didn't really get into stanford
what occurs at the end of their
conversation is an incredibly
intimate moment between the couple that
was totally improvised
it came about just as they were ending
the scene so the moment is partially
noah and lana's own insecurities about
getting the moment just right
as well as the honesty that resulted
from how strongly they were feeling
their character's emotions
it's the perfect way to end their heart
to heart and it wasn't the only
spontaneous addition to the scene
lana condor revealed on twitter that
when peter tells lara jean she should
have gotten in
because she's smarter than him her
response was a total slip up that she
didn't mean to say out loud
you smile in your sleep
an improvised decision that made it all
the way from the first movie into the
third
is lara jane's lock screen if you
wondered why it looks like someone else
snapped the picture of the couple
it's because the photo's an actual
candid picture of noah and lana that was
taken by one of the crew members while
the actors were relaxing behind the
scenes
while filming the first movie they
decided they just had to include the
adorable shots of the actors in the film
and it looks like it was romantic enough
to be featured in all three movies
genius then
genius now another example of trevor and
chris's epic flirting comes from the
second movie
when madeleine and ross had an ingenious
idea to include
real whipped cream in a scene the script
said that the two should just be
flirting by the stairs
while peter and lara jean are having a
conversation but the actors decided to
upgrade the moment by asking the props
department and catering team
if there was any whipped cream they
could use they found some and spent the
entire scene having some sticky fun
while lana and noah were busy with their
lines
in a shot by shot video for netflix noah
and lana came clean about that carnival
scene
they just said run around do whatever
you want the pair was in charge as they
explored the carnival grounds for about
20 minutes while the cameras followed
them around
catching them doing everything from
taking selfies to eating cotton candy
there were a few extras on the set to
make the scene look more crowded
but lana and noah were the only people
riding the rides and enjoying the
amusements
it was also unbearably hot while filming
and it was all shot on a rainy day
though you wouldn't have been able to
tell from all the carefree fun lara jean
and peter
are having fun fact this scene was
actually filmed while on set for the
third movie
even though it was part of the second
film one particular bit of improv is
madeleine arthur's
favorite when chris approaches the crew
to dig up the time capsule
she's carrying a shovel trevor
questioning what she's up to and her
response were completely improvised
i just buried a dead body both ross and
madeline agreed that it was
exactly the kind of witty answer you'd
expect from chris
i'm glad i decided to dress up me too
it's my my dad's we can't help but swoon
over a guy with some musical talent but
it's not just
john ambrose who's good at the piano
jordan fisher is incredible
off-screen too and that romantic moment
when he plays a melody for lara jean and
bellevue
was improvised jordan came up with his
own melody while talking to lara jean
and it ended up in the final cut it was
a challenging scene though with jordan
admitting that playing a good melody
and remembering his lines at the same
time isn't exactly a piece of cake
jordan also said on twitter he might
release an official version of the song
one day
and we'll be impatiently waiting to see
if it'll happen
i'm sorry isn't this character long
thong
duck during movie night with lara jean
and kitty peter
moving the popcorn over before a pillow
fight starts was noah's idea the scene
didn't play out the same way every time
they filmed it
sometimes the popcorn wasn't in the way
at all but the take where peter moves
the bowl
ended up being too perfect to choose
anything else
it's incredibly smooth shows off peter's
responsible side and highlights his
adorable bond with kitty
hey i'm tired can i use you as a pillow
director susan johnson is constantly
singing noah centennial's praises
especially when it comes to his
completely romantic improvisations
the scene where peter spins lara jean
around in the lunch room has become
known as
the pocket spin and it was noah's idea
johnson recalls that he did it in
rehearsal and she loved it so much that
they changed the entire scene around to
include it
okay but you kissed me first
this is not negotiable noah centennial
is naturally flirty and his expressions
add a certain
flair to every romantic gesture in the
hot tub scene splashing water around to
punctuate how peter was feeling was a
spontaneous gesture from noah
at first his hot tub vibe is more
flirtatious and then when he splashes
the water you can see some of his
frustration
his ability to get all of this across
with just a movement or a look is a big
part of why noah was cast as peter in
the first place
speaking of getting things across with
just a look lana condor's
judgy face is one of lara jean's
defining aspects
and it was something noah pointed out
during their very first chemistry read
what hmm you do this thing you had this
like this whole like judgy face
scenario going on when peter comments on
it in the first movie
it was actually an improvised line
directly inspired by noah
poking fun at lana's expressions during
their auditions
the scene where lara jean and chris
arrive at the ski lodge is an unscripted
moment between best friends
their discussion of chris attending an
edm concert was never written in their
script
i saw on her snapchat she was up all
night at this edm
concert thing and madeline recalls that
the line was completely ad-libbed
it was easy to come up with
conversations lara jean and chris might
have since madeline and lana get along
so well in real life
we'll leave you with a fun bonus moment
inspired by the movie's cast
in lara jean's list of peter's favorite
movies you can spot
x-men apocalypse which was lana condor's
film debut
there's also charlie's angels which
starred noah centineo
shazam which starred ross butler and dr
sleep which featured peter's father
henry thomas
what a great way to pay homage to an
incredible group of actors